[Applause]
good evening uh now let's get one thing
clear right from the start I am gonna be
speaking to you this evening with a
British accent so do be prepared for the
worst you here to come with a little
more authority than you're used to and
you could have spoken like this that's
the tragedy this could have been your
voice the sonorous vowel sounds could
have spewed from your mouths and all you
had to do all you had to do was just not
throw our tea into Boston Harbor and you
couldn't do it the only time that would
have been acceptable would have been if
you'd thought to pre boil the ocean
maybe add a splash of milk and a sugar
lump I don't know how you take it but
primarily I wanted to come here this
evening to tell you that it's not easy
being British as Kermit so nearly sad
the reason being it is impossible for me
as a British citizen to go into any
Museum in any nation on the planet earth
without within five minutes starting to
feel guilty you have no idea what that
feels like
you will oh you will one day all this
shame will be yours my American friends
for you have taken the baton of
imperialism from us and you are running
with it quite impressively I don't you
know then around 50 years you'll hand it
over to China who are waiting like a
coiled spring and they will sprint
towards Armageddon and that is how the
world will end
sort spoiler alert
Sorry Sorry it's annoying when people do
that now the world is in a mess at the
moment and right at the center of that
mess is the economy nowadays and I don't
understand economics I don't get how it
works I've lived for 30 years on this
planet to elsewhere and
I still don't understand it to me
economics is like the Dutch language I'm
told it makes sense but I seriously have
my doubts I want to understand
so I even bought a book to try to
explain economics to someone without the
capacity to understand it and I love one
lesson which was incredible and that is
I wanted to share with you that any
nation's economic strength is solely in
the hands of its citizens in your hands
your ability to buy things or if you
want to be really great as a nation your
ability to buy crap and that is when it
hits you that is why America is still
the greatest economy on earth because
you people cannot be beaten as a citizen
of the world let me tell you it is
intimidating intimidating but we
invented words if I say intimidating
that's now the correct word that's why
we're so good at Scrabble
that's it easy I saw an item in a shop
window in a mall in Connecticut which
stops me dead in my tracks and I mean
that I was moving I saw this item and
all of a sudden I wasn't moving anymore
it was and I promise you this is true an
inflatable BBQ now
you know we should take a moment
together to let the gravity of that sink
in it was a full functioning barbecue
with inflatable material around the
outside of it so that you like the man
on the front of the box could cook while
swimming is there any greater example of
what it is to live in the freest nation
on earth than that I don't think so I do
I do I want to cook while swimming no I
have absolutely no desire to do that
whatsoever would I like the option of
cooking while swimming why yes I would
as an American I believe I have that
right and if you are still unsure about
our ability to waiver
the current economic storm then allow me
to present you with Exhibit B the Oreo
pizza now wait wait you might look at
the Oreo Peter and think that is a
reprehensible foodstuff I put it you
that that is the single most patriotic
item I have ever seen in my life
how I spat up a flagpole get children to
swear allegiance to that in the morning
have that fluttering in the moonlight at
Yankee Stadium as a single tear spills
down Derek Jeter's cheek because that is
the biggest and greatest answer to
terrorists you could possibly issue by
hosting the Oreo Pete's up a flagpole
what you're essentially saying is there
is nothing you can do to us we are not
already doing to ourselves
you got me a to light I'm sorry you are
not quick enough thank you John
very well done thank you so much so many
questions but I have to ask you you are
you are from England where any one of
you from um well I'm from being from all
of my family from Liverpool Osborne in
Birmingham so okay you come from from
from England what do you think of our
process here are our election process
it's now your job to comment on this
what's your take on it's long yes really
long yeah what it lacks in democracy it
makes up for in length yes william
britain invented democracy don't listen
to what the ancient greeks said that was
naked wrestling yes I was there at the
start I went to the the first Republican
candidate debate in Simi Valley which
interesting was exactly as much fun as
it sounds there was an amazing moment of
political theater when all at that point
10 potential leaders of the free world
Ross the same question that question was
who here doesn't believe in evolution
and three of those men raised their
hands and then none of those three men
put their hands down and said only
joking you don't get that confidence
elsewhere on the planet no no no very
well done there is only one democratic
nation on the planet that has a
respectable turn now obviously it's bad
here and it's even worse in bryn
Australia Australia has a good Australia
has a good turnout a hundred percent
voting they have in Australia now yeah
how we act on this it's illegal not to
vote it's brilliant it's but who'd have
thought they were capable of that kind
of thinking down there must be the blood
rushing to their heads I don't know I'm
not a scientist
the the problem they run into is that
people have now started voting drunk
really it's true this has got so bad
they're suggesting closing all pubs and
bars next election days reports being
released saying that voting drunk
affects your ability to vote by 18
percent which I think we're not being
really drunk in my life when I've truly
let myself down as that would affect my
abilities votes by and this is just a
ballpark figure but by to walk and yet
this same report yes
voting drunk actually makes you more
right-wing really excited not see that
coming now it's against our popular
notion of the drunk man yeah I love you
oh bloody love you I cannot justify
continued expenditure on the welfare
state
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I've often said that drunk often very
nicely done hey thanks so much for
coming in our program The Daily Show
airs Monday through Thursday 11 p.m. on
Comedy Central and County Central
Presents John Oliver terrifying times
that premieres April 20th at 10 o'clock
p.m. please come back
[Applause]